Before we wrap up our work with the pseudo-Facebook data, let's hear from Dean
again about another technique that you can use in your work as a data analyst.
>> Much of the analysis we've done so far
focused on some pre-chosen variable, relationship or question of interest.
We then used EDA to let those chosen variables speak
and surprise us. Most recently, when analyzing the relationship between
two variables we look to incorporate more
variables in the analysis to improve it. For
example, by seeing whether a particular relationship
is consistent across values of those other variables.
In choosing a third or fourth variable
to plot we relied on our domain knowledge.
But often, we might want visualizations or
summaries to help us identify such auxiliary variables.
In some analyses, we may plan to make
use of a large number of variables. Perhaps,
we are planning on predicting one variable with
ten, 20, or hundreds of others. Or maybe
we want to summarize a large set of variables
into a smaller set of dimensions. Or perhaps,
we're looking for interesting relationships among a large
set of variables. In such cases, we can help
speed up our exploratory data analysis by producing many plots
or comparisons at once. This could be one way to let
the data set as a whole speak in part by drawing
our attention to variables we didn't have a preexisting interest in.